messieurs
[musique]
d'un bonsoir nous recevons aujourd'hui
pour une chaîne interne qui s'appelle
singer view on vous reçoit dans le cadre
de vos activités autour de la blocs
chaîne qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous en
dire est ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succinctement primavera
honneur à chercher
au cnrs à la
recharge se concentre essentiellement
sur les aspects juridiques et
à c'est
tout petit tour vers l'université
d'harvard non oui je suis assez
chercheuse associée oui
fini comme moi
j'ai d'ailleurs primavera comme designer
je suis dit fais novès une officer de
beijing qui est infrastructure
de partage de données décentralisée en
français ça donne quoi petit fils abattu
le fils à directeur
de l'innovation donc
j'ai travaillé dans pas mal de poètes
auparavant dans les grands comptes
samsung nokia orange ce genre
d'environnement où je pilotais les gros
programme d'innovation c'est
tout cela je travaille sur un sujet
important qui est l'identité numérique
et comment on peut partager des données
de manière intéressante et équitable
avec price benzakour privatisation
français mais c'est à dire que
l'utilisateur peut choisir ce qu'il va
décider de dévoiler comment il peut le
dévoiler prendre un plein contrôle sur
ce qui veut partager éventuellement
jusqu'à ce qu'on appelle du seo
knowledge pauvres c'est à dire que je
peux prouver avoir un fait sans le
dévoiler je peux prouver que j'ai 18 ans
à dire que je suis je peux prouver que
j'ai des revenus dans cette tranche sont
donnés mes revenus je peux prendre un
certain nombre de choses sans dévoiler
le fait exactement en fait ce qui
garantit mon anonymat on va revenir sur
ces sujets un peu plus tard on va
commencer par être très pédagogique
autour de la blood chaîne on a dans
notre communauté des gens très affûté
sur ce sujet là mais on va commencer là
les premières minutes par être
pédagogique avec la primavera c'est quoi
la baule chain le sujet la question
bateau qu'on doit vous poser à chaque
fois ça sert à quoi s'est fait pourquoi
sécher pour qui ce
passait j'ai combien de minutes pour
expliquer sa bouche pour une petite
heure donc
c'est une base de données décentralisée
qui
à part certaines particularités a
premièrement donc une copie de cette
base de données est
détenu par tous les membres du réseau et
à tous ses membres du réseau suivent
le même protocole et donc à a donc à
selon de la blood chaîne il ya des
protocoles différents et en
[grognement] règle générale donc on peut
ajouter d'après certains critères de
l'information sur cette base de données
mais on ne peut pas l'enlever et chaque
information qui incorporait sur cette
base de données est signée avec la clé
privée donc de la part de la de l'acteur
qui va enregistrer ces données ce qui
fait que donc on a sept une forme de d2d
tabilité et donc à tout moment en
observant la blocs chine on peut savoir
qui a fait quoi et quand à
et puisque donc puisque chaque individu
détient une copie de la blocs chine
c'est donc il ya le réseau est très
résilient puisque battant qu'il ya une
personne qui détient ce cette
base de données elle peut enfin elle
peut de nouveau se répliquer et est
de plus en plus que c'est signé avec la
clé privée c'est impossible ensuite pour
une personne qui a effectivement exécuté
une transaction de dénier de prétendre
en fait de ne pas l'avoir exécuté et
a donc ça c'est la fonctionnement
on va dire de base et puis ensuite il ya
tout le mécanisme donc comment est ce
qu'on a sur la la sécurité de cette base
de données comment est-ce qu'on s'assure
que les gens ne vont pas essayer de
d'incorporer
donc des informations qui suivent
effectivement le protocole mais qui en
fin de compte sur incompatibles les unes
avec les autres donc notamment lorsqu'on
parle des cryptes de monnaie ou on doit
échanger de l'argent a donc il ya des
règles précises sur quand est-ce que je
peux dépenser de l'argent donc je dois
effectivement avoir l'argent dans mon
compte mais évidemment il y aurait la
possibilité que j'ai dit bitcoin je vais
envoyer 10 bits comme d'un côté et 10
bits comme de l'autre les deux
transactions elles sont solides d'après
donc mathématiquement elles sont
correctes mais évidemment les deux sont
incompatibles les unes avec les autres
et donc il faut créer en plus de ce
protocole donc qui va analyser la
validité des transactions il faut aussi
un mécanisme qui s'est donc le mécanisme
de consensus qui va déterminer laquelle
de ces deux transactions et saltigué
considérer valides puisqu'elles peuvent
pas être valide toutes les deux mais
puisqu'on n'a pas cet acteur centralisé
qui va déterminer laquelle de ces deux
transactions a été effectuée
en premier il faut donc trouver à
d'autres mécanismes et donc quand le
mécanisme notamment celui identifié par
bitcoin c'est le prof work preuve de
travail en français à qui en fin de
compte c'est tout simplement tous les
tous les membres du réseau vont donc
essayer de trouver la solution à un
problème informatique
le premier qui trouve la solution il va
enregistrer les transactions dans un
bloc est communiqué au réseau le réseau
va contrôler que il ya bien là solution
à ce problème informatique est donc la
transaction qui a été sélectionné dans
le bloc et qui ensuite a été communiquée
réseau sera donc la transaction valide
et donc ça résout ce grand problème qui
était très difficile à résoudre jusqu'à
présent à du double spending au double
dépense en français grâce
donc à une approche probabiliste ou en
fin de compte petit à petit on ad on a
tous les noeuds qui essaye tout ce
qu'ils font là qui font la course pour
retrouver ces blocs et dès lors qu'ils
trouvent les blocs pourquoi est ce
qu'ils sont en train de dépenser toutes
ses ressources énergétiques pour trouver
cette solution ils vont être récompensés
avec des buts quand même dans le cas du
pétrole oui sinon
petit rebond là-dessus quelque chose à
rajouter oui moi je sais ce qu'on peut
pas dire beaucoup de choses
l'introduction
moi j'ajouterai simplement que
aujourd'hui
dans la presse on parle beaucoup de
décentralisation et donc on associe
naturellement la table obtiennent à la
décentralisation en effet pour pour
autant des centristes on ne veut pas
dire blokhine au fait ça c'est un sujet
qui m'intéresse c'est à dire que j'ai
prêché en l'occurrence mais pas
seulement on peut avoir plein de
services qui vont qui vont se construire
sur aidés à s'entraîner sans mais qui
n'ont pas besoin de deux blocs chaîne
pour valider les transactions d'ailleurs
quand fait d'où la non je dis simplement
que la décentralisation pour moi ça
commence par le fait que l'utilisateur
puisse avoir ses données dans son
téléphone et quand tu 17h à celle menée
en son téléphone il peut par un
protocole échangé il venait avec
quelqu'un
et dans beaucoup de cas d' usage en fait
ne pas nécessiter de bloquer sur
ça je dirais que la blocs chaîne n'est
pas la décentralisation c'est un aspect
de la blood chine la bloquer en ce qu'il
ajoute justement aux architectures
décentralisée traditionnel c'est ce
concept de une vérité unique que tout le
monde est d'accord donc si on doit tous
à être d'accord que il ya un état de
l'art et on est tous d'accord sur cet
état particulier du réseau dans ce cas
les réseaux décentralisés traditionnel
c'est compliqué parce qu'on a pas
effectivement donc ya pas de protocole
de consensus et la bloque gène introduit
donc ce protocole de consensus au dessus
d'un réseau décentralisé de façon à
bénéficier de la décentralisation au
niveau de l'infrastructure mais d'une
centralisation logique on va dire c'est
à dire qu'il y à un état qui est unique
à tous les membres du réseau bon
là on va parler un peu plus concret
parce que pour les 30% de novices qui
assure ne résout ce doit être du chinois
aiment la bonne chaîne ça peut servir à
quoi concrètement 10 à part l'aspect
monétaire l'aspect bitcoin vous
prêtez pas port et pour moi ils
l'obtiennent s'éteint on parle souvent
de l'internet de valeur donc échange de
valeur dès lors qu'il ya d'une
transaction qui permet d'échanger de la
valeur ou de participer
les blocs chaîne peut être intéressante
donc ça le nombre de cas d'usagé très
très large ça va 2 d'une capacité à ce
que deux personnes puissent transactés
sans intermédiaire de confiance donc se
payer de personne à personne trois
des banques sur ceux payés sans
intermédiaire de confiance donc jusqu'à
des
cas où il déforme un pull sophistiqué où
il ya des participations
qui sont régulés et on parle de la
question de la gouvernance donc sur
l'énergie on peut imaginer que on va en
fait dans la dans les logiques
décentralisée à intégrer des règles de
fonctionnement en fait c'est là à mon
sens ou dans les blocs chaîne où j'ai
dansé décentralisation il ya un truc
très intéressant c'est le sujet de la
gouvernance mais du coup quand on parle
de gouvernance alors hand sur un sujet
qui est qui est curieux parce qu'on dit
bon ok on va les centraliser la
gouvernance on veut plus l'intérieur de
confiance donc on va s'arranger entre
nous c'est intéressant seulement rendre
dans les dynamiques sociales il ya des
choses qu'on existait avant il ya pas
mal de théorie donc
une gouvernance par exemple celle qui
circule beaucoup c'est lola cratie qu'en
fait c'est des capacités d'auto
organisation on
va voter on va définir des règles qui
vont assurer le fonctionnement de la
communauté et c'est intéressant
seulement c'est un peu codé la
démocratie voilà
aujourd'hui
on joue aux apprentis sorciers ont fait
des expérimentations ici et là
il ya il ya le problème de ces
décentralisations c'est qu'elle implique
beaucoup de participation c'est à dire
que je peux pas juste venir et je vais
consommer un truc c'est que s'il n'ya
pas le bon équilibre dans la
participation à
partir des règles de gouvernance
finalement on se retrouve comme on l'a
vu avec et terium d'ailleurs quand il ya
un dysfonctionnement à à soro se
recentrer sur quelques acteurs clés à
l'époque où il ya eu des actes sur
intérieur on a tout de suite demandé à
vitaly depuis terrine qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire ou ce qu il ya un problème
donc une des centres et la gouvernance
n'est pas si simple en fait ça veut dire
que il doit y avoir capacité à définir
des règles allaient en intelligible
design on parle d'un fort dense et
comment moi je peux rendre intelligible
à quelqu'un qui vient ces règles là au
fait que si c'est pas juste un discours
entre codeurs donc comment je peux faire
que quiconque qui rejoint cette
communauté comprend les règles de cette
communauté peut participer peut
permettre à ce que ces règles évoluent
dans le temps et que y ait un équilibre
entre une stabilité et la dynamique
c'est du fameux on sait les analogies de
système de biologie en fait ainsi si
c'est trop si les règles ne changent pas
trop dans le temps sammer tout seul et
si c'est donc la résilience si au
contraire on est trop sur la la
l'efficience sam euro6 donc l'analogie à
la biologie fonctionne comment on trouve
le point d'équilibré en trinquet intra
système qui est suffisamment résilient
un système qui est suffisamment
dynamique pour faire que les gens
peuvent participer et du coup ça pose la
question de aussi d'un ensemble plus
large alors quand on dit concevoir un
écosystème avec une gouvernance ben moi
je suis un peu frustré de voir des cas
où ça je trouve que la portée et pas
assez grande je je je trouve intéressant
en revanche l'analogie était au système
monique c'est à dire les systèmes mono
knicks et on a une organisation et
communautés dans ce quartier les gens
ont décidé de faire des trucs qui ont
défini des règles il fonctionne avec le
koup et n'hésite pas et
[rires] ses règles finalement elle
fonctionne pour la petite communauté
mais à un moment la neige la communauté
va vouloir grandir elle va chercher
chercher à trouver une compatibilité
entre des règles d'une communauté
semblables ou complémentaires et on a
comme ça dd au long c'est à dire des
unités qui vivent avec leurs propres
règles mais qui vend tellement vont
trouver des compatibilités voix des
règles qu'il est qu'ils sont au dessus
en fait et c'est bien là son sont
intéressants donc on rentre dans des
analogies à des systèmes organiques qui
dépasse un petit peu ma seul bloc chain
mon écosystèmes à moi mais et pau qui
pose la question de comment je me mets
en relation avec d'autres choses autour
en fait la
démocratie coude et le démocratie non en
fait je voulais répondre à ta
internautes question avec plusieurs sur
c'est quoi cette utilisation de la
bloquer je
pense que tu peux les tu peux les quatre
essais en trois catégories a donc un
c'est tout ce qui touche aux
applications financières donc un crypto
monéteau cannes etc à deuxièmement c'est
tout ce qui touche au registre au
cadastre donc c'est d'utiliser la
bloquer non plus comme un outil donc
pour échanger de la valeur mais tout
simplement comme ça ce registre
décentralisée certifiés et incorruptible
dans lequel donc je peux notari zay
1 certains documents je peux je peux
prouver que quelque chose s'est passé à
ce moment là et c'est donc c'est tout
c'est toute une catégorie très
différente de l'application mais qui en
fait c'est une application des prises de
base la blood chez nous tu peux vraiment
construire des applications plus
sophistiquées et ensuite la troisième
qui est probablement la plus
intéressante mais encore là - explorez
on va dire c'est tout ce qui touche aux
modes contracte et donc la possibilité
de déployer des logiciels sur une
glauque chine c'est-à-dire qu'au lieu
d'avoir un logiciel qui va tourner sur
un serveur centralisé et donc qui est
contrôlé par l'opérateur de ce serveur
on va pouvoir déployer ce logiciel qui
va ensuite être exécutées de façon
distribué par tous les noeuds du réseau
et donc ce qui rend en fait est
impossible de façon unilatérale a
modifié influencé ou même arrêter
l'exécution de ce logiciel est donc
lorsqu'on se déplace donc les marques
comptera que c'est n'importe quel type
de logiciel qui va déployer sur la blogo
chaîne et lorsqu'on se déplace donc
lorsqu'on crée des logiciels qui sont
effectivement conçu pour opérer et pour
être exécutés de façon autonome et
indépendante donc même de même deux des
acteurs qu'ils ont déployés ou qu'ils
n'ont développé on rentre dans ce
nouveau monde d'aider à eau donc des
organisations autonomes décentralisée
ils sont et c'est là où justement il ya
toutes ces nouvelles questions de
gouvernance qui ce qui arrive puisque on
a un mécanisme qui en fait on va on va
déterminer les règles de gouvernance sur
la blogo chain et ensuite on va
permettre donc aux individus d'interagir
les uns avec les autres uniquement en
suivant ce protocole secret
plantes plantes aux ide oui raconte nous
un peu ça ah si tu me le disait je
l'amenais mais a cessé de l'expliquer
sans l'illustration mais en gros c'est
j'ai essayé de représenter dans le monde
physique qu'est ce que c'est qu'une des
aot parce que c'est très discret site
est très difficile d'expliquer c'est
quand même nous avons surtout aux
avocats aux juristes et donc la plante
aux ide c'est une block tchenguiz lie
forme ce qui se traduit en français
comme une forme de vie fondée sur les
blocs chaîne et l'idée c'est donc de
représenter donc qu'est ce que c'est
qu'une des ao c'est quelque chose qui
est autonome donc qui n'est contrôlé par
personne c'est quelque chose qui est
autosuffisant c'est à dire qu'il est
capable de l'identité algorithmique est
capable de collecter les ressources
nécessaires pour pour
opérer et comme toute autre forme de vie
qui est capable d' anciennement de se
reproduire et donc une plante aux rides
c'est la version android d'une plante et
donc c'est une petite créature en métal
qui se nourrit avec des bitcoin est donc
là la reproduction d'une plante aux ide
se fait donc la plante est une elle va
essayer de se faire très jolie une façon
d'attirer les gens pour leur donner un
peu de cryptes aux monnaies a donc on va
lui donner des bitcoins ou de l'éther
peu importe et à chaque fois qu'elle
reçoit un peu d'argent elle va faire
monter dedans fin elle va faire un petit
un petit chaude pour dire merci et en
fait donc la plante au heat va qu'on va
moniteur est constamment sa
balance sur la blogo chin et lorsqu'elle
se rend compte qu'elle a accumulé
suffisamment d'argent pour se reproduire
ça va activer en smart contracte sur le
blog chaîne détériore qui va ouvrir un
appel d'offres et donc va inviter bas
des artistes des designers n'importe qui
en fait à soumettre des propositions sur
comment est-ce qu'ils envisagent de
créer la prochaine quant aux ide puis
pour les facilités dans la reproduction
et ensuite donc toutes les personnes qui
ont financé la plante aux ide peuvent
voter sur ces différentes propositions
et chaque vote va être pondéré avec la
quantité d'argent qu'ils ont financé le
smart contracte va traiter toutes ces
informations on va identifier qui est le
gagnant et ces deux là donc la plante au
heat va donc exécuter une transaction
sur la blogo chez eva donc transférer
l'argent aux gagnants et va donc
l'embauché à pour créer une copie dalmat
et donc à halle
l'idée c'est de représenter
effectivement désormais puisque grâce à
la bonne chaîne on peut en a plus besoin
d'aller financer un artiste et espérer
que certains artistes il va continuer à
créer des oeuvres qui nous place on peut
finalement directement financé l'oeuvre
d'art elle même et c'est ensuite
l'oeuvre d'art qui va décider qui va
sélectionner quel est l'artiste qui a le
droit de la reproduire et qui va donc
l'embauché pour créer une copie
d'allemagne rémy
quand tu entends plantes aux ide book
jeune artiste et je vais dire presque
une dame s'est
fait penser à quoi un sujet qui
m'intéresse parce que j'ai travaillé sur
le sujet de l'animisme quand j'étais
dans une boîte finlandaise nokia avec
l'idée quand on chercherait une forme
d'intelligence artificielle qui soit un
peu différente de ce qui avait été
explorée aux mighty donc je compte je
comprends le sujet et l'idée d'y
projeter quelque chose de quelque chose
d'humain dans la technologie m'intéresse
énormément en
fait pour le coup ce
qui est intéressant est curieux dans
cette rhétorique c'est qu'en fait
l'humain passe en second plan en fait on
met l'accent sur un processus qui est
qui nécessitent plus d'intermédiaires
moi
[raclement de gorge] ce qui m'intéresse
c'est de poser la question comment on va
garder des gens
des personnes là dedans c'est à dire que
l'aspect
humain dans la façon dont on va négocier
des règles dont on va discuter dont on
va arbitrer dont on va trancher comment
des communautés d'intérêt vont grandir
donc je trouve que la métaphore est
super intéressante elle
amène la question de comment on modélise
des gouvernances en fait ça c'est le
grand sujet pour n'hésitez pas à
interroger aux troupes de ces grands
sujets donc la notion d'autonomie
intéressante mais moi
ce que je trouve vraiment
un vrai sujet c'est comment on va
modéliser une gouvernance et comment
elle va éventuellement et évoluer je
t'ai interrompt excuse moi parce que
c'est en
fait donc le l'idée avec la plante ride
c'est que a donc j'explique un petit peu
plus en détail c'est qu'en fait elle va
adopter différentes stratégies de
reproduction donc comme tout être humain
il ya plusieurs stratégies pour essayer
de se reproduire on peut soit jouer un
petit peu sur l'aspect physique pour
essayer de se faire beau fort à soi on
peut jouer sur l'aspect plus
intellectuel on essaie d'être amusant
d'être intelligents etc et nos forces ça
fait partie de l'aspect physique et
donc une cantine c'est un peu pareil
c'est à dire que la plante aux idées là
une stratégie aussi bien esthétique donc
elle va essayer d'avoir
les caractéristiques nécessaires pour
attirer les individus qui vont donc
vouloir lui donner de l'argent pour
qu'elle se reproduise mais elle peut
aussi adopter donc corps donc à l'achat
clin d'oeil de la son propre code
génétique et le code génétique incorpore
aussi bien des caractéristiques
physiques que des caractéristiques
intellectuelle ou de gouvernance
c'est-à-dire qu'ils programment sont bas
donc chaque artiste donc lorsque la
plante il va embaucher un artiste
l'artiste il a une liste de critères qui
doit respecter qui font partie du code
génétique de cette plante aux ide qui
sont aussi bien par rapport à l'aspect
esthétique al'aspect de gouvernance donc
la façon dont les dons là dans le smart
contracte sur un terrain on va opérer et
l'idée c'est justement d'avoir cet
espace d'algorithmes évolutionnaire là
où donc les plantes aux ide qui sont les
plus populaires elles vont accumuler le
plus d'argent et donc voir se reproduire
et elles vont évoluer en différents
espaces et donc faites en fin de compte
on va on va découvrir quelles sont les
caractéristiques aussi bien les
caractéristiques esthétiques que les
caractéristiques de gouvernance qui vont
rendre la plante et de la plus adaptée à
son environnement et donc par exemple on
peut imaginer il ya une plante qui est
quelqu'un de riche charitables donc elle
va donner la moitié de l'argent qu'elles
collectent un an profite à il y à aussi
potentiellement une plante aux ide qui
est super capitaliste que lorsqu'on
investit dans la plante reid pour lui
donner de l'argent pour se reproduire
elle va fournir des retours sur
investissement ainsi investisseurs et en
gros l'idée c'est vraiment d'aller
explorer en s'appuyant donc sur ce
mécanisme évolutionnaire d'aller
explorer quelles sont les différentes
formes esthétiques ou de gouvernance qui
vont à fait être les plus tu accélères
le pendule qu est ce qui ressort à 1 on
n'a pas trop accélérer la pendule donc
on sait pas pour l'instant s'il y en a 9
mai au niveau de la gouvernance elles
sont pas très original ses traits plutôt
créatif pour l'instant rémy
reprend la parole je trouve intéressant
la métaphore ça pose la question de ce
que je trouve très méritant là dedans
c'est que tout d'un coup ça pose la
question d'un écosystème dans lequel
l'utilisateur est peut-être plus la
personne n'est pas au centre de truquer
une plante et l'analogie pourrait vous
valoir pour la planète c'est dire est-ce
qu'on peut inventer un processus est une
monnaie qui ferait que quand on s'engage
dans quelque chose quand on consomme
quelque chose on participe et quelque
part il y a il ya un enjeu qui
transcende 2 l'entreprise morphisme en
fait je trouve que cette métaphore
m'intéresse à ce titre là ces filaments
dans les cryptes au mollet on trouve des
trucs qui ont des ambitions de plus ou
moins intéressantes sauvent
en cas relativement court terme et
spéculatifs ce que j'entends ici c'est
quelque part il ya un projet auquel j'ai
envie dans lequel j'ai envie de rentrer
qui me dépasse un petit peu qui la
dimension organique peut laisser
entendre aussi que c'est quelque chose
qui n'est pas juste une communauté de
personnes et ça peut être comment je
fais que on agit de manière plus
responsable vis-à-vis de l'environnement
et que dans ce processus là on en code
des valeurs qui dépassent les petits
intérêts interpersonnelles en fait
qu'ils aient acquis 20 au gault desquels
quel va être le conseil de surveillance
décodeur alors là on vante dans le truc
encore une fois les métaphores sur qui
sont liées à la biologie sont
intéressantes j'ai vu toujours un modèle
qui était vaya beau ce style beaux
modèles que je souhaite c'est
[grognement] modèle
viable soutenable
qui disait mais finalement on a dansé
système là des analogies au corps humain
et donc il ya une gouvernance qui va
définir les grandes orientations
il définissait cinq principes ensuite en
dessous il y à des
enjeux de stratégique et de coordination
intergroupe puis en dessous
l'organisation
d'une unité puis en dessous
l'organisation du conflit puis en
dessous l'organisation des fonctions de
base et donc il faisait la mj le cerveau
jusqu'aux muscles et ça ça m'intéresse
parce qu'aujourd'hui à l'exception du
projet de primera on voit pas de projet
de blocs chaîne qui ont une envergure
qui soit une vraie porte et humaniste
qui traitent des sujets contemporains ok
l'écologie l'énergie
s'il voulait pas aborder ces sujets là
mais il balance on
va comment
on peut trouver à aider donc alors
effectivement on commence à se réguler
ça ça c'est un vrai sujet aujourd'hui
c'est un peu vite et c'était que les
blocs chaîne convoi elles sont au niveau
des fonctions des muscles si tu veux par
essence dans cette échelle là on n'est
pas encore à des niveaux de gouvernance
qui font se coordonner d'une des unités
les groupes qui ont leur autonomie mais
qui ont besoin de collaborer pour un
projet qui les transcende on n'y est pas
encore ça ça c'est un sujet qui
m'intéresse alors la métaphore me parle
pour le coup assez zitte pas j'appelle
ça une [rires]
portée qui dépasse son système humain
ouais en fait le pas moi la raison pour
laquelle je me suis plongé dans la blog
team pour commencer c'était justement
parce que j'étais absolument intéressé à
explorer les différentes formes de
gouvernance qui peuvent émerger au
dessus de ces plateformes est en fait
c'est assez intéressant d'observer dans
les plateformes existantes qu'elles
aient effectivement la forme de
gouvernance qui est introduite est en
fait il ya ceux il ya cette espèce
d'ironie de paradoxes d'une certaine
façon c'est à dire que donc on a une
infrastructure décentralisée évidemment
on veut y insérer une forme de
gouvernance décentralisée parce que
sinon pourquoi est ce qu'on offre à se
décentraliser et le prendre c'est que
jusqu'à présent tout ce qu'on connaît
comme infrastructure décentralisée en
fait c'est là c'est les dynamiques de
marché et donc la plupart des
infrastructures de blocs chaîne que l'on
voit aujourd'hui elle adopte un système
complètement fondée sur des dynamiques
de marché donc soit c'est à selon des
road de la quantité de ressources
informatiques que j'investis dans le
réseau soit ca selon de la quantité de
tocane que je possède est en plein du
folk explique pardon il faut que le cas
tous les jetons donc [rires]
les crypto monnaie on va dire donc les
crypto monnaies qui sont sous jacente à
la belote chaîne où les tripes de
monnaie que l'on va créer au dessus de
la boxeuse et c'est en fait c'est très
intéressant parce qu'effectivement en
théorie bah oui c'est vrai on a un
système de gouvernance décentralisée
fondée sur la marché mais on sait très
bien que le marché et éventuellement il
va évoluer et il bosse il va avec va se
concentrer il va créer des oligopoles à
moins qu'il y est mission qui le protège
et donc l'ironie c'est qu'en fait on a
assez de ce désir de décentralisation
qui est très fort mais en fait on
s'arrête à la théorie on s'arrête à
avoir une infrastructure de centraliser
et une une forme de gouvernance
théoriquement décentralisée est en fait
lorsqu'elle évolue qu'elle commence à
devenir extrêmement centralisé tant pis
alors que c'est dans ce cas pourquoi est
ce que on ne remplit pas l'objectif
initial qui était effectivement la
décentralisation et le danger de tout ça
je pense que c'est qu'effectivement
parce qu'il ya ce désir de justement de
ne pas formaliser ne
pas avoir cette structure hiérarchique
et c'est en fait on se retrouve dans des
situations où très souvent il y a d il
ya des hiérarchies de pouvoir il y a des
il ya des individus qui ont beaucoup
plus de pouvoir que d'autres mais c'est
invisible sans les pouvoirs invisible
qui sont dans la je sais pas le traduire
en français mais c'est la tyrannie de la
structure lacenas donc la tyrannie du
manque de structures ou en fin de compte
lorsqu'on a une structure on va savoir
exactement qui est responsable de quoi
et donc on va pouvoir faire appel et on
va pouvoir qu'on considérait qui est
responsable d'une décision alors que
lorsque justement il ya ce set un format
lité mais il ya quand même des pouvoirs
il a quand même des acteurs qui est qui
est un exercice beaucoup plus de pouvoir
que d'autres mais on peut pas savoir qui
c'est et donc on se retrouve
effectivement dans une situation où il
ya énormément de pouvoir dans certains
groupes mais il n'y a plus la
transparence il n'y a plus la
comptabilité anvers et c'est un homme
concret bah tout simplement tout les
tous les réseaux bitcoin a été riche en
exemples concrets sur bitcoin si par
exemple je suis la cia et que je veux
faire plomber le cours du bitcoin qu'est
ce que je fais je
vais aller vendre très rapidement pour
faire peur pour faire écrouler pour
faire peur aux petits porteurs qui vont
se dépêcher de vendre et ensuite me capa
et manger ensuite les racheter très
rapide ou
a potentiellement aussi je suis là si il
ya plein de mécanismes il ya plein de il
ya plein de centre de pouvoir qui sont
un petit à petit qu'on peut identifier
donc il y aller
les mineurs donc les personnes qui est
fournissent leurs ressources
informatiques aux réseaux énergétiques
pardon l'énergétique exactement donc en
fin de compte baa l'origine c'était
conçu comme un système extrêmement
décentralisée aujourd'hui ça s'est
consolidée dans dans un très petit
nombre d'acteurs qui en fin de compte
contrôler à sur bitcoin tata 5,5
acteurs qui contrôle plus de 50% du
réseau et donc bah si on a la
juridiction sur ces acteurs on peut
effectivement contrôlé un peu l'on peut
lire réguler on peut leur demander
notamment de censurer certaines
transactions de prioritiser certaines
transactions sur d'autres après il ya
les galets ne l'ya laineux qui ont un
rôle spécial sur le réseau c'est à dire
les les échanges les explorateurs du
bloc chez nous même les commerçants qui
acceptent des crypto monnaie qui ont
évidemment même si même si le réseau est
un réseau décentralisé ses acteurs ils
ont beaucoup de pouvoir parce qu'en fin
de compte toute décision qu'ils vont
faire par rapport à choisir une version
de la bloquer ou de l'autre tous les
utilisateurs vont suivre leur décision
et donc même si c'est un réseau
théoriquement décentralisée on se rend
compte que au niveau du traitement des
transactions s'est extrêmement
centralisé au niveau de la décision de
quel protocole adopté dans le cas dans
le cadre d'une décision qui doit être
prise il ya pareil il ya des acteurs qui
ont beaucoup plus de pouvoir et ensuite
il ya évidemment les développeurs qui en
fin de compte en le pouvoir très
important sur pour décider quel là
quelles modifications à implémenter et
me qu'est ce qu'on pense oui je rebondis
sur les points essentiels que tu as
évoqué qui sont effectivement il ya une
dynamique sociale c'est pas nouveau tout
d'un coup on met du code dedans mais on
peut revisiter les formations de groupes
et formations d'influencé s'est
amplifiée par ces phénomènes qui sont
automatisées mais finalement on revient
sur les problèmes de 2
de d'organisation
et de dynamique politique tant et si
bien la métaphore été très juste qu on
est sur des modèles spéculatifs quand on
dit même je crois vitaliy buts et rinne
a fait la proposition d'une fuite archi
dans laquelle au lieu de voter pour une
personne en politique on veut entrer
pour un élément de son programme en
pariant sur la capacité de cet élément
du programme à être réalisés donc c'est
vrai qu'on retrouve systématiquement des
formes de spéculation sur sur des
chaussures des projets il
ya près d'une raison à laquelle sa
dysfonctionne c'est que les personnes
que le processus de blocage c'est qu'on
peut avoir une clé privée mais il n'y a
pas de on ne sait pas qui est derrière
en fait et la question de l'identité
dans l'ex dans la participation au broc
chaîne est un peu mise de côté en fait
c'était c'était fondateur d'ailleurs une
façon dont l'imaginaire anarchique
je pense de ses saisissantes si on a
moins il me semble qu'il ya un si on
veut permettre de de trouver des formes
de régulation à différentes échelles
comme je vais vous que tout à l'heure il
faut que l'utilisateur puisse pas être
identifiée au sens je vais retrouver qui
s'est exactement mais qu' on est
identique une identité qui puisse être
quand même référent référence et ce
n'est pas le mot mais que
je puisse garantir que j'ai été ré j'ai
le droit de participer j'ai le droit de
voter j'étais les moeurs éléments
d'identité qui justifie que je peux
faire telle chose et en fait on a
l'impression que dans la bible
obtiennent on a collé un processus sans
intégrer la dimension de l'identité de
l'individu qui participe en faites pas
comme monture et vont dire est là dessus
mais ça c'est le sujet qui nous
intéresse évidemment chez g près duquel
on se peut on peut se bloquer ce plug et
à toutes les blocs chain avec notre
infrastructure d' échanges de données
mais notre sujet c'est une entité en
fait parce qu'en fait on considère que
finalement sous couvert d'anonymat on
danse est bloqué il ya des dynamiques
qui conte contrôle pas parce que
l'utilisateur ouais
il ya des choses qui sont hors la loi
demain verra saurait mieux dire que moi
son livre explique bien la dimension
utopique dystopie sûr sûr sûr chaque
case usage effectivement son livre donc
les nerfs de l'eau je recommande je
le trouve qu' il manque une part qu il
ya une loi il ya un pan dhombres complet
sur tous les usages de la question de
l'identité de l'individu mais
je pense que les trilles intéressant
c'est justement lorsqu'on crée ses
réseaux de nîmes d'une
certaine façon il ya la question donc
est-ce qu'on veut identifier la personne
en tant qu'individu unique ou bien de
quoi en fait on a besoin pour
effectivement permettre à cet acteur 7 à
7 personnes d'utiliser ou d'accéder à un
service et je pense que ce qui est
intéressant avec la blood chaîne c'est
que justement parce qu'il ya quand même
cette direction donc de pseudo limité
pour commencer que ça nous permet
d'explorer en fait des mécanismes qui
sont pas vraiment des mécanismes
d'identité comme on le conçoit
aujourd'hui où effectivement bas j'ai
mon passeport et il ya une personne qui
me d'anti fille comme une personne mais
c'est plutôt la question de quelles sont
les caractéristiques que je possède ou
quels sont les critères qu'un service va
demander pour que je puisse y accéder et
donc avec la prochaine on peut
effectivement créer des systèmes je
pense que l'identité en tant que unicité
de la personne c'est très compliqué
parce qu'en fin de compte on peut pas
avoir l'unisson peut pas garantir
l'unicité d'une identité sans avoir un
système centralisé qui va effectivement
s'assurer qu'il n'y a pas des duplicata
par contre ce qui est intéressant c'est
tout ce qui concerne donc les les
credencial ite et donc la capacité de
2,2 pas de m'identifier moi en tant que
primavera mais de certifier le fait que
je possède certaines caractéristiques
est de pouvoir prouver grâce à shen ou
quoi que ce soit de pouvoir prouver que
quelqu'un non identifié pas en tant
primavera mais à identifier ma
caractéristiques et la teste et donc
ensuite je peux utiliser cette
attestation pour accéder à un service
sans que ce service n'est jamais besoin
de demander l'information de moi-même ou
sans que ce service est besoin de savoir
qui je suis en tant que personne et donc
en fait on crée on décentralise d'une
certaine façon la notion d'identité et
en vala la fragmenter en les différentes
caractéristiques qui représente sept
personnes et c'est ensuite à moi de
choisir comment est ce que je veut
combiner ses caractéristiques pour créer
une identité partiel qui va me permettre
de motifs y est à certains services sans
avoir besoin de prouver son identité ou
une unicité de nice et ont créé doute
[rires]
la seule différence c'est que nous on
parle d'attributs qui confort qui
constitue une identité l'introduction
est très juste je rajouterai simplement
que nous notre challenge c'est de ne pas
être dépendante d'aucune blocs chain
donc il existe des choses qui
permettrait de partager des attributs
dans un écosystème donné donc été rome
par exemple
on pense qu'il faut être détachés des
blocs chaîne pour être compatible avec
toutes les blocs thing donc on a d'abord
un passeport universel qui devrait
permettre d'échanger les informations
avec n'importe qui et que donc
l'utilisateur du coup on est vraiment
propriétaires parce qu'il est même pas
dépendant du dernier qu'au système comme
ils te répondent par exemple après
c'est très juste de dire
qu'effectivement nous on peut partager
la somme de fait qui est demandé mais on
peut au gie aussi joué sur le fait je
démontre que je possède un fait sans me
donner je prouve que j'ai plus de 18 ans
sans appel 0 knowledge proof la preuve
sans
partage de connaissances et je prends je
prouve que je sais où que je possède un
fait sans le partager ce qui est
l'antithèse des modèles actuels avec les
facebook connect et autres nous demande
un email un nom et serra et il faut
l'envoyer là on va démontrer qu'on sait
où qu'on possède une information qui
nous rend légitime qui nous donne un
droit d'action ça c'est incroyablement
puissant parce que on a à la fois
effectivement de la nomination c'est
nécessaire et l'apprécier approuvé les
droits et on reste identifiable comme un
élément comme une personne néanmoins
avec qui participent dans un écosystème
donc nous ce qu'on perd mais c'est
partager des droits obtenir
des mandats en échange donc en échange
d'un partage et des faits pardon en
échange de fait j'obtiens des droits et
des mandats donc j'ai le droit de voter
j'ai le droit de partager un servi j'ai
le droit de
d'actionner quelque chose je garde les
reçus de transaction c'est que là on est
dans la décentralisation complexe on a
fait une transaction je garde ma part ça
veut dire que c'est la part de ma
réputation que je garde parce que sur
les plateformes actuelles que soit
airbnb weeber la réputation est bloqué
dans cet écosystème c'est ma réputation
de passagers ou de chaussures scheiber
elle est stockée scheiber je peux pas
m'en servir dans une plate forme
concurrente dès lors qu'on stocke sa
réputation on peut on peut la faire
valoir ailleurs et on peut broadcast et
les services soi même et ça on pense que
c'est le socle pour permettre de à
toutes les blocs chain d'exister parce
que ça permet de voter deux partitions
des soucis avec personnaliser les
services par
ailleurs c'est nous permet d'adresser
plein de cas d'usagé qui ne s'use pas de
blocs tellement fait donc on permet des
transactions de personne à personne qui
sont un coût énergétique 2,77
millions de fois plus économe qu'une
transaction sur était rien alors tu
parles de d'énergie on va rentrer dans
le dur parce que c'est ce qui fait un
petit peu phosphorer tout le monde sur
plateforme
notre communauté nous envoie des
questions petite question d'internet
compte tenu de la consommation
énergétique des principales crypto est
il souhaitable de les voir se développer
davantage alors
il ya plusieurs réponses à paris comment
sais tu vas y annoncer la première alors
on m'a posé souvent cette question et
certains m'ont dit mais est ce que
quelqu'un s'est amusé et ses deux
compères comparer le coût énergétique
d'une infrastructure bancaire
aujourd'hui par rapport aux beach boys
et j'ai pas trouvé de données donc si
les gens dans la communauté on déchiffre
ça m'intéresse en revanche on sait qu
effectivement aujourd'hui et les coûts
sont très élevés pour le bitcoin
détériore et que ces couloirs s'écoula
sont exponentielles en fait est que ils
sont beaucoup considèrent
très problématique je pense qu'ils le
sont parce que bien des égards et plein
de transaction qui nécessite pas
développé une fête comme nous on en
perdait de pair à pair on a on a un
protocole open source qui peut être dit
et qui permet de transférer des
informations qui ne pas besoin de blocs
chase et à l'information elle est passée
et on n'a pas besoin de boxer et ça
c'est une première partie de la réponse
la deuxième partie de la réponse c'est
que je [grognement]
pense que on [gémissement]
devrait pouvoir permettre
d'émerger des des crypto monnaie qui
intègrent la question de notre
écosystème et de ce conte comment on
peut refinancer des développements et
que la question de l'écologie soit
intégrée en fait et aujourd'hui les gens
de la blocs scène soul food ils disent
simplement bon ben la question de
l'énergie sera elle va se régler dans le
temps ça sera pas un souci moi je pense
que c'est un souci on a pas on n'a pas
de marge pour dire si dans 20 ans ou
dans dix ans ou dans cinq ans on pourra
faire mieux on a bien le temps
d'attendre je suis pas de cet avis là et
je pense qu'au contraire les projets
bloqués ne se sont pas assez fédérer sur
un projet qui transcende les relations
humaines de l'évoquer tout à l'heure et
qui disent un peu comme la quand la tva
a été inventé on peut on peut on
pourrait en crypté un système puisque
c'est l'internet de la valeur la bloquer
non pourrait en crypté quelque chose qui
permettrait de trouver un équilibre
qu'il n'est pas juste nos intérêts
personnels en fait la
raison pour laquelle j'aime pas répondre
à cette question c'est parce qu'en fait
masser une question qui se pose tout le
temps et à la fin je réponds toujours la
même chose donc je vais encore répondre
la même chose c'est-à-dire que
l'effective m'emballe il y a les cryptes
de monnaie actuelle dont la plupart vont
utiliser le concept de preuves de
travail trop fort qu qui par sa
définition en fait la cccc
conçu pour consommer puisque la
consommation et ce qui permet de
sécuriser le réseau et donc l'idée sous
jacente de cette consommation
énergétique c'est que plus la valeur du
réseau augmente donc plus il ya de
l'argent qu'on peut se faire en essayant
de coopter le réseau plus il va falloir
consommé 2 j ai donc plus ça deviendra
difficile de coopter le réseau et donc
il ya cet espace de cercle
vicieux d'une certaine façon ou dès lors
que la crypte monnaie devient de plus en
plus valorisées sur le marché il y aura
toujours plus de personnes qui vont
essayez donc de miner ses cryptes aux
monnaies pour obtenir des récompenses et
donc ils vont faire augmenter la
sécurité du réseau a donc théoriquement
sur l'énergétique et la consommation
énergétique dont théoriquement l'idée
c'est là la consommation énergétique
participe en fait c'est le coût que l'on
veut ou qu'on ne peut que le coup qu'on
au peigne pour sécuriser le réseau après
évidemment on est arrivé à des niveaux
qui sont vraiment ridicules en termes de
consommation et plus plus le temps passe
plus ça devient ridicule avec le sens
bah il faut il faut aller voir toutes
les statistiques assez chaque jour il ya
une statistique différente mais un je
pense à tout ça sur internet tu cherches
quelle est la consommation énergétique
de bitcoin ils vont me donner tous les
pays du monde potentiellement je crois
le dernier c'est israël qui le
consomment de la même quantité que le
que le pays d'israël mais ça change tous
les jours en fait est un la la la
continuation de la de la réponse c'est
tout simplement la continuité enfin dans
la continuité de la réponse c'est que en
fin de compte on n'est pas obligé
d'utiliser des systèmes de profs de
travail c'est le premier système qui a
été implémentée par bitcoin c'est
celui-là qui a adopté par la majorité
des cryptes monnaie mais il ya
énormément blême informatique qui
est fondée sur la consommation
énergétique c'est vraiment conçu pour ça
il y a en fait va toutes les nouvelles
nouvelles typologies de consensus donc
proof of tech ou preuve dans jeux en
français qui en fin de compte
permettrait potentiellement d'assurer la
même typologie de sécurité mais sans
impliquer cette consommation énergétique
et donc les débats notamment intérieur
ils sont effectivement et pour l'instant
ils sont encore un profond fork mais ils
ont là ils ont dans leur feuille de
route à l'idée de passer un pronostic et
il ya beaucoup de il ya énormément de
recherches qui se fait actuellement sur
quelles sont les nouvelles mécanisme de
consensus qui effectivement permettrait
après la différence
bisontin ça te parle oui toute écoute
bas profèrent
foire qs et à l'innovation incroyable de
profs marque c'est qu'il ait réussi à
résoudre le problème de mézin team fault
tolerant se fait pas comme on dit ça en
français et en fait l'innovation poupe
c'est ça par rapport à pomper ou w voilà
de pro à voir que c'est la preuve de
travail et mais la façon dont il a
résolu ça c'est pas comment la plupart
des des approches auparavant avait été
fait qui essayait vraiment de résoudre
le problème il a résolu d'une façon
probabiliste c'est à dire qu'en fait
c'est tout simplement probabilistic mans
c'est pratiquement impossible
économiquement parce que ça devient
extrêmement coûteux de coopter les
raisons mais en fin de compte etc seule
innovation la vraie innovation de
natation de cannes nakamoto qui a donc
inventé le prophète work c'est d'essayer
de résoudre le problème du byzantine
folk avec une approche probabiliste et
c'est incroyable c'est une innovation
incroyable après le problème c'est que
évidemment on se rend compte bayadh yade
et il ya des effets collatéraux qui sont
la consommation énergétique et donc
maintenant il ya des gens qui essaient
de résoudre le même problème toujours
avec une approche probabiliste et
économique et donc comment est-ce qu'on
rend le système tellement coûteux a
essayé de le coopter et donc il n'y a
pas une cape c'est pas une solution
parfaite c'est juste une solution que un
niveau un certain moment tu arrives à un
niveau où c'est tellement couteau de
tricher que tu as une probabilité
extrêmement basses que effectivement il
y aura une faute
8 aujourd'hui
on voit pas j'entends tous ces points et
je moi
je m'interroge sur la durée qu'on de
l'expérimentation en fait alors je
reviens sur le point qui est que il ya
plein de partage de situation de partage
de données qui ne nécessitent pas des
blocs chaîne en fait je je
mon point c'est que aujourd'hui
décentralisation
et galbe lokchine c'est une erreur et
décentralisation le partage de données
prouve partage de données anonymes
peuvent se faire de sens ensemble
obtiennent et que j'ai
avec la surconsommation d'énergie reste
un vrai problème parce qu'en fait on sur
utilisent les blocs chains quand dans
bien des cas on n'a pas besoin du tout
en fait ça c'est un peu mon leitmotiv et
qu' il ya les cas on peut faire des
transactions qui nécessitent pas des
blocs chain of est alors
en
revanche oui une innovation que je
trouve intéressante c'est la question du
smart contracte mais là encore un
smartphone trac pour un utilisateur qui
vient qui n'est pas un geek
comment on va créer la ford ans de ce
que le contrat serait vraiment comment
un non geeks va pouvoir vérifier que le
contrat n'est pas frauder mais quand
même sur les intérieurs des bugs dans
les contrats qui ont créé des deac
important donc l'utilisateur moyen fait
confiance à une infrastructure et quand
une fraude arrive si les tromper parce
que dans le cas extrême on éviterait
l'intermédiaire de confiance mais il
s'est fait avoir par des implémentations
de oui oui mais je pense qu'aujourd'hui
là je
reviens sur la question du tiers de
confiance pour le coup est ce que ces
systèmes fonctionnent parfaitement sans
tiers de confiance et c'est pas c'est
pas une évidence en fait moi je pense
que les acteurs les tiers de confiance
historique vont survivre cette situation
même peut-être même se renforcer un
paradoxe je vois bien les banques
certifier des données par exemple si on
manque une question d'internet un peu
bisounours le bitcoin permet-il à
l'homme de sortir du monopole des
banques centrales
je
reprend la métaphore de tout à l'heure
des systèmes qui se régule à différents
niveaux moi je crois que je
crois pas à l'autorégulation en fait
donc oui je crois qu'il y aura besoin de
forme de régulation qui sont qui ont des
intérêts qui sont pas forcément qu'on
verrait plutôt ex union soviétique
non non non je crois que dans l'analogie
à l'organisme que j'ai évoqué tout à
l'heure la gouvernance c'est quelque
chose qui se qui se partagent et qui
transcendent des intérêts de petites
communautés qui ont leur propre blog
shane donc je sais plus comment ça c'est
organisera donc dans le détail en
revanche je suis convaincu que
l'autorégulation c'est enfin le voit sur
les plates formes qui étaient des
centres et qui ce qu'ils ont vécu et
bénéficier de la décentralisation et qui
on y perd centraliser les données enfin
la grande plateforme mondiale de réseau
social aujourd'hui l'autorégulation
qu'elle prône comme est l'option on voit
bien que ça marche pas en fait
j'ajouterai
qu'en fait le monopole de la banque
centrale ces bien pensants de bitcoin
pour pour l'éviter puisque la plupart
des de l'argent s'est créé non pas par
la banque centrale mais par les banques
retail quoi et la différence avec
bitcoins et que le deal qui porte
l'enfant [rires]
avec bacon et avec les crypto ménages
gênante je pense que c'est intéressant
ça veut pas dire qu'on va se débarrasser
d'un monopole puisque très probablement
balle la monnaie fiduciaire va rester la
monnaie fiduciaire mais ça permet en
fait à des communautés de créer leur
propre monnaie et de dictée par eux
mêmes quels sont les règles d'émission
de cette monnaie donc ça permet une
expérimentation sur plein de choses
qu'en fait auparavant on avait du mal à
expérimenter on avait les monnaies
locales peut-être mais là on peut
vraiment expérimenté avec des systèmes
monétaire alternatif un niveau global
comme la d'unités angie one
ce n'est pas un célèbre le léman qui
fonctionnent sont bloqués autour du lac
léman qui permet une économie circulaire
donc on peut acheter sa baguette de pain
en l'aimant et le boulanger achète sa
farine en l'aimant et ça fonctionne pas
trop mal finalement après la différence
avec les monnaies locales
traditionnelles c'est que souvent elles
sont
bac tu as quoi
par de la monnaie fiduciaire alors que
là on peut effectivement créer des
monnaies dont la valeur n'est pas vacth
par une autre monnaie mais la valeur des
rives de la deûle utilité de cette
monnaie donc on va créer des confiance
passait pas décemment la confiance en
fait de la confiance allait déléguer à
la technologie donc si on fait confiance
à la technologie c'est fini mais c'est
pas ça qui va donner la valeur à la
monnaie la valeur de la monnaie dépend
va aider à la valeur intrinsèque c'est à
dire quelle est l'utilisation la valeur
d'utilisation de cette monnaie après il
ya la valeur externe sac qui aujourd'hui
c'est toute la vraie valeur qui en
contrôle sur le marché c'est
essentiellement extrinsèque c'est-à-dire
tout ce qui est spéculation donc quand
tu regardes bitcoins est assez
intéressant parce qu'effectivement
beaton quelle est la valeur intrinsèque
de bitcoin c'est pas les cheveux pas
combien elle est maintenant les milliers
de dollars auxquels
elle auquel elle est vendue aujourd'hui
sur le marché c'est le fait que la
valeur de bitcoins et que la seule façon
que je puise que je peux utiliser ce
réseau de payement décentralisée kbit
coyne c'est en dépensant des bitcoins au
niveau d'aidé des transactions de la
même façon avec et terium la valeur
intrinsèque des terres sais que je peux
utiliser les terres pour pouvoir
exécuter ses logiciels sur sept blocs
chaîne de façon décentralisée et en fait
on peut maintenant crée donc avec toutes
les organisations décentralisées au
comment tu veux les appeler on va créer
des monnaies donc c'est tout les récits
eau etc dont la valeur intrinsèque mais
qui aujourd'hui n'est pas du tout
reflétée sur le marché parce que la
valeur du marché c'est purement de la
spéculation mais la valeur intrinsèque
c'est pas parce que il y a derrière de
l'or ou une autre monnaie la valeur
intrinsèque de ce toqué nous de ce jeton
comment tu veut l'appeler c'est la
valeur que je considère recevoir lorsque
je le dépense pour obtenir un service
qui va être fournies par sept par cette
plateforme donc notamment dans le cas de
à imagine
ya une plate forme donc pour le stockage
décentralisé je
vais avoir un tout cas n'en jetons qui
me permet donc de d'accéder à cette
plateforme est donc de charger mais mes
données sur ce réseau décentralisé la
valeur de ce taux cannes c'est la valeur
que je perçois du service qui m'est
fourni et donc ça c'est la valeur
intrinsèque et dont tu peux créer d
assez intéressant parce que tu peux
effectivement créé de la monnaie magic
internet mans ni la monnaie interne est
magique en français dans la valeur va
émerger au fur et à mesure que la valeur
du service augmente par rapport au
marché et évidemment ensuite il ya
aujourd'hui bas c'est surtout parce
qu'on va on va jouer plutôt avec la
spéculation avec ses tocane et donc en
plus de ça j'ai toute la valeur ex37 qui
s'ajoute on
va revenir sur la finance parce que tu
m'as l'air de connaître un peu le
dossier rémy
une petite question d'internet est ce
que le développement de l'informatique
quantique pour vous remettre en question
la viabilité des blocs chaîne j'ai
entendu ce sujet plusieurs fois je
suis pas technique cette technique pour
pouvoir répondre à cette question je
n'ai pas la réponse j'ai
demandé séquelles cette question un
plusieurs personnes qui s'occupe
justement d'informatique quantique ils
m'ont donné une réponse je vais essayer
de traduire la réponse qu'ils m'ont
donnée c'est qu'en fait il y a deux
approches comment est-ce qu'on va donc
réagir
à l'arrivée de l'informatique quantique
donc il ya une approche qui est âgée le
lien en anglais on dit qu'elles sont
connues voilà donc un sequans une
résistante et l'autre ces postes coin
tout ok donc l'idée avec cointreau
résiste 1 2 c'est que tout simplement on
va à bas dès lors que l'informatique
quantique se développent et donc ça
devient beaucoup plus facile de dérivés
la clé privée par rapport à mes dents en
gros toutes les cryptographes vos liens
voilà deux fois les mets donc le jour où
il ya là lundi quantique qui arrive
c'est là que les blocs chine c'est le
dernier des problèmes parce qu'on a tout
notre système de chiffrement qui
s'écroule mais l'idée c'est que m'a tout
simplement on va adopter des nouvelles
fonctions d nouvelle mécanique donc on
va passer sur le système la petite et
c'est au lieu de la voie est donc mais
en gros c'est une course c'est à dire
qu'au fur et à mesure que l'informatique
se développe on va créer des fonctions
plus complexes qui vont donc demander
plus de ressources la latence la latence
qui vint donc ça c'est le plus assez
lecointe une résistance est à dire que
on continue au fur et à mesure on va
parce que l'informatique quantique va se
développer de plus en plus on va devoir
créer des fonctions de plus en plus
complexes le post coïtum qui je pense
est là la solution beaucoup plus
intéressante c'est que c'est de dire
qu'en fait ok on va éliminer le problème
à la source c'est à dire que le problème
avec l'informatique quantique c'est que
effectivement avec les mécanismes
actuels que l'on a actuel ou futur donc
même le système avec la tis a le même
problème c'est dire qu'on peut toujours
dérivés par rapport à une clé publique
on peut avec du brut fort sinon on va
tester tester tester on va récupérer un
certain moment quelle est la clé privée
qui permet donc de déchiffrer et l'idée
donc avec le poste coin comme c'est que
on ne va jamais dévoiler quoi que ce
soit donc tout ce qu'on va stocker donc
notamment sur la blogo chine on va
stocker dh on va stocker des leds proof
on va on va stocker de l'information qui
en fait ne fait que prouver quelque
chose mais qui en tant que telle ne peut
pas être dérivé on n'a pas la matière
première même avec l'ordinateur le plus
puissant du monde on a rien qui nous
permet en fait de faire du bruit de
forcing pour essayer de le dérivé est
donc là on dans ce cas là la question ce
ne se pose plus puisque effectivement le
que ce soit l'informatique actuelle où
l'informatique quantique à le lab l'ofce
ne sert que comme une base de données où
on va enregistrer des preuves de quelque
chose mais on va jamais à incorporer ou
enregistrer une information qui elle
pourrait effectivement dévoiler quelque
chose qui ensuite permettrait de
corrompre le système oui dans
[raclement de gorge] bien des cas on
n'aurait pas besoin de la projeter sur
la blogo tiennent par ailleurs aussi
pour éviter le
problème on pourrait imaginer que
vraiment les données sont stockées de
manière décentralisée non pas sur une
block tonnes mais dans mon téléphone
tout simplement --auquel cas
facile d'y accéder non non laplaud ction
et plus générale la prochaine lettre
et les transparents on va chercher des
choses et sur le téléphone si c'est
ancré petit rhin cas à c'est plus facile
enfin
ça dépend de l'importance de la personne
si [rires] c'est vraiment vu craquer un
téléphone effectivement c'est un point
de venir habilité enfin l'idée avec ça
c'est vraiment que justement la blood
chine sa soeur un peu comme cette
base de données centralisée logiquement
où on veut stocker toutes les
informations et donc moi si j'ai besoin
de savoir quoi que ce soit je vais
contrôler évidemment on va jamais
stocker les données personnelles sur la
bottine on va utiliser les blocs chine
comme un système de contrôle
d accès de permissions excellent ou deux
pour stocker les crédences mais en fin
de compte l'information n'est jamais sûr
la bloquer en est même donc aujourd'hui
sur la blogo chine on va stocker
certaines informations telles que
notamment la clé publique et là on va
même pas ce qu'est sa dessus de façon à
ce qu'on ne puisse rien dériver oui
c'est ce qu'on fait nous en fait on ne
publie que des révocations de droit en
fait sur les blocs tonnes on publie le
moins possible donc révocation de droite
que j'échange des données c'est au
knowledge prouve je partage des données
j'obtiens des droits et si quelqu'un si
on veut révoquer les droits de quelqu'un
ça mérite d'être publié sur un blog
shane et à défaut on publie moins
possible sur un octet notamment
parce que nous on essaie d'être
complètement j'ai des pères complet en
français rgp d
il ya une des barres gp2 qui veut dire
règlement général de la protection des
données ce bien travaillé
il ya un débat sur glock tnr les [__]
donc pour faire court les gens de la
ville obtient les non-dits le rgpp a été
pensé avant la bloquer ni les cas il est
caduc et de l'europe
dit non pas du tout c'est un bloc ten de
s'adapter il ya un vrai débat sur du
coup qu'est ce qu'ils méritent d'être
publiée sur une blokhine ou pas sachant
que de fait la bloquer n'est pas très
compatible avec la loi puisque on ne
peut pas effacer les données alors
que la loi dit on à droit de
modification de rétraction on peut
effacer on peut porter ces données
valables obtiennent a priori sait pas
quand tout à fait conforme avec les
secours il a bougé de la tête ce que
c'est un bon c est donc aujourd'hui loup
on a un usage très très raisonnée
tenable obtiennent plus
vers un mur gp10 d'adoption oui enfin je
pense que c'est c'est très bien parce
qu'en fait c'est effectivement ça ça
oblige les gens à réfléchir à quelles
typologie d'informations stockées sur la
blogo chine est très souvent on n'a
jamais envie de stocker les données ne
voulons vous pas stocker les données sur
la blanche et ne sert que comme un
système de preuves donc on va stocker
peut-être le hd données de façon pour
avoir vérifié l'intégrité on va stocker
la preuve qu'un document a été signé par
deux parties ne va jamais stocker le
document où les données personnelles
ahlmann donc là là là j'ai des pères
d'une certaine façon elle permet de l
obligeant fait à réfléchir un petit
mieux un petit peu mieux pour comment
est ce qu'on vaut effectivement utilisé
la blood chef au final c'est ça le débat
était virtuel et ceux qui sont pros
blocs terre nous disent aujourd'hui
passe à nous ça nous invite à avoir un
usage plus raisonnée il ya eu quand même
des blocs times qui publiait des données
personnelles alors dans l'évocation des
jeux parents nommé plusieurs
les quais qui mettait les données
personnelles
de l'identification dans la boue
tiennent leur propre autre
question d'internet démocratie liquide
pour l'interrogation larry les sig
application du vote par proxy alors la
question de l'arrivée six doigts tcp/ip
on m'a dit ouais sur [grognement] le
système de vote il ya plein de trucs
après peut-être en parlait il ya aussi
les systèmes quadruple
commencé en français voilà quadrettes
pratiquer votre corps à tiques il ya
plein d exploration à votre politique ça
consiste à dire que je peux voter une
première fois puis si je veux voter
donner plus de poids à mon vote a
rajouté un vote en fait je paye chaque
vote je rajoute le carré de la première
mise c'est ça et donc ça veut dire qu'à
la fin il ya il ya une régulation qui
est plus naturel que la fameuse tyrannie
des communs ou une voix un vote et le
problème de la majorité qui est imposé
par ce système là donc il ya des
explorations sur les systèmes de vote
qui sont plus vertueux dont celui en
sachant que un nom
c'est je pense que pour l'instant on n'a
pas vraiment donc la question c'est quel
typologie de vote à le vote notamment
les élections et cetera ils doivent
avoir de caractère essentiel donc un
c'est la vérifiabilité donc moi en tant
qu individu qui a voté je dois pouvoir
vérifier que mon vote a été comptabilisé
et de ses l'incorruptibilité où le
secret c'est à dire que je ne peux pas
en tant qu'individu avoir la possibilité
de prouver à qui que ce soit pour qui
j'ai voté parce que sinon je peux me
faire convaincre et est donc a priori
ces deux caractères sont extrêmement
complexes d'avoir en même temps la blocs
chez nous fournit une vérifiabilité
excellente mais évidemment puisque un
blog chine c'est transparent et
auditables ça devient difficile en fait
de l'incorruptibilité devient difficile
on peut pas on peut pas courant dans le
sens qu'on veut pas modifier le vote
mais je peux me faire comprendre parce
que si je peux vérifiée et prouvée pour
qui j'ai voté je peins parcourant près
donc actuellement ils y apparaissent je
ne connais pas une solution actuelle qui
a été vraiment prouver qui fonctionne
qui permettrait d'avoir les deux mais il
ya beaucoup de recharge qui se fait
notamment avec les héros knowledge proof
ou au morphing encryption etc qu'ils
essayent effectivement d'obtenir aussi
bien une vérifiabilité c'est à dire que
je peux vérifier que tout au long de la
chaîne mon vote a été comptabilisée dans
le pur pour déterminer l'élection mais
malgré ce malgré que moi je peux
vérifier je ne peux pas le prouver à
quelqu'un d'autre et donc ça c'est une
question extrêmement complexe et je
pense qu'il faut encore pas mal de
travail pour vraiment réussir à résoudre
cette dichotomie mais potentiellement il
y a des il ya effectivement des
opportunités à exploiter sur
internet je
sais pas s'il valide parce qu'à l'heure
actuelle une intelligence artificielle
pourrait arriver intégrer une doctrine
alors
ça c'est un sujet intéressant de moi je
crois beaucoup aux hybridation donc je
crois que à la fois on va avoir des
libérations sur décentralisation
décentralisation parce que la doctrine
ne permet pas d des vitesses d'accès à
des données actualisées suffisante
pour avoir des services avec du temps
réel et
l'intelligence aux tertiales va être
aussi intéressantes pour arriver à
développer de la connaissance et il ya
des expérimentations qui essaient de
faire des combinaisons donc
donc
sur la combinaison des techno clairement
il y aurait il y aura des choses qui
vont se passer oui c'est sûr et c'est la
question c'est est ce que l'intelligence
artificielle va prend fin va prendre la
main sur une bouteille pour arriver
intégrer une doctrine sous
quelle forme c'est prendre la main la
contrôler c'est une question que j'avais
posée est ce qu une haute exigence
artificielle peut contrôler nocturne
parce
que je sais [rires]
pas si je comprends la question mais si
j'entends prennent la question de ma
propre façon c'est à dire est ce qu'on
peut
codifiée au sein d'un smart contractent
une intelligence artificielle
je pense que c'est ça la question ao
musique en elle tout le monde soupçonne
voilà donc potentiellement oui pourquoi
pas après qu'est ce que ça dit en
intelligence artificielle aujourd'hui
n'importe quel algorithmes c'est une
intelligence artificielle donc oui est
ce qu'on peut avoir des systèmes
sophistiqués de machine learning
pourquoi pas c'est possible pour
l'instant on n'a pas vraiment vu mais ça
soulève une question extrêmement donc je
profite de ces questions pour
pour des quelque chose que j'ai envie de
dire qui
en fait donc il ya une dissection
extrêmement intéressantes à faire entre
la l'autonomie donc l'autonomie
décisionnelle qui effectivement donc
l'intelligence artificielle et
l'autonomie opérationnelle qui en fin de
compte c'est la blocs chaîne donc
l'autonomie décisionnelle c'est la
capacité donc de prendre des décisions
par soi même mais très souvent tous ces
mécanismes de l'intelligence
artificielle et sont contrôlés par un
opérateur qui peuvent effectivement les
modifier les influencer ou les stopper
potentiellement qu'ils alors que la
l'autonomie opérationnelle est très
intéressante on peut avoir un système
qui est très très stupide c'est à dire
qu'il n'a aucune capacité de prendre des
décisions par lui-même c'est juste un
petit script qui va s'exécuter de façon
autonome mais la particularité de la bo
jean de cette autonomie opérationnelle
c'est qu'on veut pas le bloquer qu'on
veut pas le modifier et donc ont créé
cette espèce d'entité algorithmique qui
qui
qui intègre en fait cette capacité donc
d'être une entité autonome indépendante
et potentiellement si on pouvais et je
pense qu'il pour l'instant la plupart
des demandes contrat qui existe sur ces
blocs jeunes sont très simples mais si
on pouvait intégrer un mécanisme
d'intelligence artificielle et donc de
combiner l'autonomie décisionnelle avec
l'autonomie opérationnelle dans ce cas
on pourrait avoir des systèmes
extrêmement intéressant où on a en a un
c'est vrai une entité algorithmique qui
peut prendre des décisions par elle-même
et en plus de ça qui est complètement
autonome de qui qui fonctionne de façon
décentralisée par la blood chef qu'elle
suppose des robots tur bat exactement
c'est celle là [rires]
la colle à la halle à l'extrême de cette
conclusion c'est ça on peut créer
effectivement des systèmes peut-être pas
des robots tueurs parce qu'en fin de
compte les robots tueurs bas il existe
dans le monde physique donc on va quand
même pouvoir les stopper mais on peut
crier des systèmes donc si dd des
systèmes de 2 les exemples qui sont
utilisés généralement c'est par exemple
les marchés d'assassinât a donc on peut
créer des systèmes ont effectivement je
vais faire des je vais faire des paris
je vais mettre de l'argent pour que je
parie qu une personne va mourir à ce
moment donné et lorsqu'il ya
suffisamment de personnes qui vont
parier d'un côté probablement ça va
encourager un autre acteur à aller
effectivement réalisé cette prédiction
est donc potentiellement ont créé un
système qui va encourager
d'aller tuer une personne mais ce
système ne peut pas être bloqué ce
système n'a pas de fin qui responsable
pour pour avoir créé ce système est ce
que c'est le développeur qui a développé
cette application alors qu'en fin de
compte c'est juste un système de
prédiction c'est juste que les
utilisateurs ont décidé de prévoir de
prédire qu'une personne allait mourir et
donc qu'ils ont utilisée qu' on peut
détourner l'utilisation de ces systèmes
est donc on peut crier des systèmes qui
sont potentiellement des systèmes
illicite des logiciels illicites mais à
différence des logiciels centralisés où
on va tout simplement aller rechercher
quelle est le serveur qui est en train
de faire exécuter ce logiciel lorsqu'il
s'agit d'une blocs chaîne soit on doit
rendre toute la ville obtienne illicites
et donc c'est à dire que toutes les
personnes qui toutes les autres
applications qui sont en train d'être
exécuté sur sept blocs chaînes sont
aussi les sites alors que c'est que ce
n'est pas le cas et donc ça devient
extrêmement compliqué lorsqu'on arrive
dans ces situations où on n'a pas la
capacité en tout cas une île et a
unilatéralement
il n'y a pas une autorité du
audio du monde juridique real qui peut
effectivement prendre la main sur sur
ces applications est la seule façon
d'effectivement de stopper ou de
modifier l'exécution de ces logiciels
s'est il faut une action coordonnée par
tous les membres du réseau qui vont
décider de modifier le protocole de la
blog team pour arrêter ce logiciel
gauche
entre temps il ya des explorations à la
darpa sur le déshabille
une intelligence artificielle qui
s'expliquerait qui pourrait sauter
compliqué dont l'as blotzheim
permettrait de certifier certaines
étapes du processus c'est une étape
avancée avant la question des robots
mais
le
lien entre l'intelligence artificielle
utilisée pour arriver à roppe faire
le processus de raisonnements à l'envers
par exemple pour les questions
d'assurance parce
qu'aujourd'hui pour ceux qui connaissent
le type learning et séditieuse où on
sait pas trop expliquer comment on est
arrivé du dans le processus comme on
était arrivés d'un point à un autre et
donc ça pose des problèmes pour
justifier cette décision ballet
classique c'est pourquoi un véhicule
décidé d'écraser un passager ou plutôt
qu'un autre canton devrait a su avoir
négocié entre les assurances comment on
peut justifier que l'automobile a pris
la bonne décision qu'il
responsable et qui est responsable
voitures
le constructeur le programmeur libère
ses appuis politiques qu'on en code fah
c'est un cas classique c'est le fameux
coup du tramway qui a été super
documenté sur internet mais en substance
et si la voiture a la capacité de
décider comment on encore d'un système
de valeurs en fait c'est la question
éthique sinon il veut vous sujet si le
chauffeur a plu est plus riche que le
piéton ou le cycliste est ce qu'on
puisse qu'il est noir ou pas noir est-ce
qu'on va encore des des règles qui
seraient discutables
ou
le concorde s'est écrasé on a bien
découvert que la valeur donc pour les
assurances d'un mot d'un passager
américain anglais et français n'étaient
pas du tout la même en fait c'était du
simple au g + 5 fois plus pour entre un
français américains par exemple donc là
on commet l'en code ça pose problème
mais c'est pas un problème nous
simplement
est abandonnée comme on doit vous
l'expliquer parce que les voitures
autonomes alors la justifier qu'on a
encore des une bonne chose donc moi j'ai
des copains designers qui travaille là
dessus chez vous chez volkswagen par
exemple qui commence à réfléchir sur
nous justement [rires]
ils veulent se rattraper je crois et
[rires] patron de audi qui ont tout l'
autre question d'internet
qui était qui arrive un peu tard de
quelles échelles de temps par le tout
quand on évoque ses sujets pour
l'interrogation les applications grand
public sur ont-ils visible dans deux
cinq dix ou 50 ans vous
battez pas alors moi je peux répondre
bah non c'est après nogueira n'ont
même pas trop ces questions bah c'est
qu'on a tous bien que nous
nous on en fera aujourd'hui un passeport
donné qu'ils existent vous pouvez
télécharger sur l'app store ou l'android
market équipe et nous le doubs vous le
trouverez sur place integrity classé
integrity on ajoute de l'intégrité dans
les transactions placement produit
senior donc ça existe c'est la deuxième
erreur je prouve tout cela on a des
choses donc c'est concret c'est là en
fait la question complot mois que la
perspective que j'aimerais donner c'est
la promesse des blocs tu es né dé
gouvernance décentralisée on n'y est pas
encore nous ce qu'on perd mais c'est que
on a un domaine de service par
lesquelles un ou plusieurs acteurs
peuvent décider des règles de qu'est ce
qu'on demande comme données quelles sont
les règles comme commuter c'est là quant
à penser à des dynamiques sociales qui
sont celles qu'on a évoqué c'est des
choses qui sont expérimental
moi
je serais plutôt à penser que on devrait
que explorer un peu avant de déployer
des choses qui sont aujourd'hui pas très
scalable elles sont pas ce cas là
pourquoi parce que quand on a dans des
petites communautés des règles de
gouvernance qui fonctionne on arrive à
distribuer les voter les participations
canton quand on change d'échelle des
gens viennent pour participer dans un
mode plus consommateurs ont un peu dans
les modèles de conception de jeux vidéo
août à sept à huit utilisateurs type
viennent pas tous avec les mêmes
motivations et je n'aime pas tous avec
une compréhension des règles et balla du
tout d'un coup ce qui est ce qui
fonctionnait bien avec une petite boule
obtiennent une petite échelle avec
l'échelle d'un quartier ou d'un projet
de recherche
c'est plus callable et donc il
faut modifier la gouvernance assez
rapidement et sur ces dynamiques là je
crois qu'on n'y est pas encore c'est
à dire la capacité du système à évoluer
dans le temps c'est mon point on n'y est
pas encore c'est définir des règles de
fonctionnement dans une comédie et ça
marche pas mal les faire évoluer à la
vitesse de la croissance d'une
communauté où j'ai rien vu qui marche
j'aime
[grognement] pas beaucoup ces questions
parce qu'en fait c'est de la prédiction
et c'est de la spéculation mais a le mot
sur motion voilà enfin [rires] on peut
répondre mais on sait pas trop ce qu'on
dit mais je pense qu'en fait c'est
actuellement il ya il ya deux obstacles
importants 1 c'est justement de vale à
l'obstacle technique c'est à dire que
pour l'instant on a beaucoup de profonde
crise aptes preuve de concept et
et plus ou moins ça marche mais dès lors
qu'on rentre un petit peu à l'échelle on
voit que immédiatement ça me bloque
parce que là blocs chaîne n'est pas
capable de gérer c'est ce nombre de
transactions et
l'autre obstacle pour moi c'est un
obstacle juridique c'est-à-dire que
actuellement on est quand même dans une
incertitude juridique c'est difficile en
fait de pour une entreprise de déployer
ses applications sans avoir une
certitude comment est-ce que cette
application va être interprété d'après
le droit ou comment est ce que le droit
va évoluer par rapport à ça et donc en
fait je pense que les deux d'une
certaine façon s'alimenter les uns les
autres c'est à dire que si on n'a pas
une certitude juridique c'est difficile
de déployer les applications si on
déploie pas des applications c'est
difficile d'observer c'est les
implications de ces applications et donc
de les réguler et donc on a un espace de
deux blocus ou étant content qu'on
résout pas un problème ou l'autre c'est
difficile d'avoir vraiment une adoption
massive de ces technologies qui
[soupir]
est sur le terrain et qui vient de
tomber quelle application côté politique
qui
fonctionne la
politique fonctionne selon toi
[rires]
j'évoquais
tout à l'heure une qui est qui est
spéculatif mais la future fut darchy qui
consisterait à spéculer sur la
probabilité de réalisation d'un projet
et non pas sur une personne primavera
l'a bien dit tout à l'heure en politique
on voit que des solutions qui sont de
type spéculatif on va parier sur la
réalisation d'un truc éventuellement si
on gagne on gagne ou on gagne quelque
chose une
forme de rémunération bon
moi je trouve que c'est pas l'éditeur
s'est pas à la hauteur des enjeux
contemporains je trouve qu'on devrait
pouvoir sur la politique on aimerait
voir une des communautés réfléchir
à une monnaie qui en crypte aurait une
valeur qui était passe les intérêts
interpersonnelles
donc j'ai évoqué mais c'est un sujet qui
m'est cher mais comment on peut en
crypté le l'empreinte carbone dans
quelque chose qui fait que finalement
quand j'achète un truc très mondain quoi
je vais acheter une chemise en coton
finalement elle a un coût pour
l'environnement qui était pas très bon
et j'accepte de payer une contrepartie
parce que je crée un déséquilibre dans
l'écosystème qu'on sait quantifier la
tracé et qui fait que cette monnaie en
crypte un système de valeurs là ça
serait un enjeu que je trouverai
ambitieux le reste
sur
la seule question du vote je trouve que
c'est pas le bon sujet en fait la
question la politique c'est d'arriver à
mettre en place une crypto monnaie qui
permettent de porter un projet qui
dépasse les petits intérêts en fait
parce que primaire a bien dit les crypto
valait extrêmement spéculative
aujourd'hui c'est des petites
communautés ont valu des blocs jeunes
qui sont ici là et c'est de l'ordre de
la fonction en fait on a pas on voit pas
encore émergé quelque chose qui enlève
d'un organisme complexe où il ya
différentes niveaux et les niveaux blocs
gènes qui régulent d'autres ouais
je vais répondre en fin de compte je
pense que c'est peut-être plus une
question de gouvernance plutôt que de
politique politique parce que ça veut
dire effectivement la
question de la gouvernance c'est
vraiment la possibilité désormais qu'on
a c'est difficile aujourd'hui
d'expérimenter avec des nouveaux modèles
de gouvernance parce qu'en fait on n'a
pas vraiment beaucoup d espace pour
expérimenter et en fait de la blood
chaîne nous permet d'une certaine façon
c'est un peu ce microcosme dans lequel
on a des communautés qui sont en fait
assez intéressé à expérimenter avec des
nouveaux modalités de gouvernance pour
l'instant il s'avère que la plupart de
ses modalités de gouvernance sont à ses
côtés marchez marchez de prédiction fut
tarki etc mais d'une certaine façon il
ya de plus en plus de projets donc il y
a il y à un wagon il y as d'aosta qu'il
ya plusieurs projets qui sont en train
vraiment de se focaliser sur
l'expérimentation
avec des moules modèle de gouvernance
qui sont des modèles de gouvernance plus
distribuer ou décentralisée et je pense
que c'est c'est quand même quelque chose
à regarder parce que effectivement c'est
là où on peut vraiment on a on a un
espace d'expérimentation fantastique où
on peut tester différents modèles la
plupart de ses modèles probablement vont
échouer mais c'est pas grave c'est juste
une petite communauté qui expérimentent
et donc en fait ça nous permet vraiment
d'avoir eu un peu le le le processus d'
apprendre parler par les échecs donc de
tester rapidement et de d'échouer et
puis de retester etc et donc je pense
que aujourd'hui parce que justement il y
à cette architecture décentralisée d'une
certaine façon pour la gouverner on est
obligé d'aller réfléchir à des choses
auxquelles on ne réfléchissait pas
auparavant parce qu'on avait une
architecture centralisée et donc par
définition on a aussi un système de
gouvernance centralisée puisque celui
qui gouverne infrastructures gouverne le
système est là donc on a la possibilité
de faire des nouvelles découvertes
potentiellement et au niveau politique
et peut-être un truc mais on est
vraiment dans le on est vraiment dans la
marge c'est ce qui s'appelle je vais pas
le dire en français non plus ça
s'appelle des centres à l'aise bloc shin
beth virtuel nation a donc ce sont des
initiatives qui ont un peu un projet
assez ambitieux de créer donc d'aider
des nations donc pas non plus des états
nations mais des nations donc un groupe
d'individus qui va se gouverner d'après
donc ces règles qui sont dictées par la
blocs chine qui vont fournir
effectivement donc des systèmes
d'identification et des systèmes de nos
tares isation et c est donc en fait
l'idée c'est d'aller analyser quelles
sont les fonctions de l'état qui en fin
de compte peuvent être remplies en tout
cas en partie par un mécanisme
décentralisée fondée sur une pop chez et
donc notamment tout ce qui concerne
l'émission d'un d'un certificat
d'identification lan autorisation de
certains informations l'émission de
monnaie etc et donc il ya ces projets
dont il y habite nachin ya culture et
c'est donc qu'ils essayent de concevoir
et après je pense le problème c'est
justement le fait qu'ils se définissent
comme étant des nations et donc
immédiatement il ya cette connotation a
essayé de faire concurrence ou de
remplacer l'état nation est donc
évidemment bonne chance mais l'aspect
intéressant c'est de voir comment est ce
que ces communautés et c'est de se
gouverner et et c'est en fait de
vraiment de créer des systèmes complexes
qui permettrait l'organisation de deux
centaines de milliers d'individus
d'après des règles qui vont être définis
donc dans de façon collective et qui
ensuite vont être
incorporer un formalisée au sein de
cette infrastructure globe chaîne de
façon à ce que les personnes peuvent
interagir les unes avec les autres par
l'intermédiaire de cette de cette
plateforme oui
il est plein d'expérimentation le il ya
même des choses qui fonctionnent sans
blocs chains apos l'entreprise
américaine qui fait de la vente à
distance de chaussures a mis en place
une organisation au look racing je crois
qu'on dit ou en fait l'individu est
responsable de il ya une espèce de
places de marché dans l'entreprise et
l'individu de voir va devoir vendre sa
capacité à contribuer sur telle partie
du projet et donc on est dans un système
totalement décentralisé dans lequel
l'individu tout seul participer
aujourd'hui
il affirme que ça fonctionne c'était
censé être un moyen de retirer du
management en réalité il ya plus de
managers parce qu'il ya quand même des
mecs à la fin qui sont là pour dire sur
ce projet j'ai besoin de cinq gars les
cinq gars il doit avoir telle compétence
et toi tu arrivé tu dis bah moi je veux
bien je suis bon et serra et puis
évidemment si tu trouves pas à
travailler suffisamment dans cette
organisation on va poser la question si
tu es vraiment légitime dans cette
organisation éventuellement tu te fais
virer il
ya les expérimentations qui fonctionne
sans donc cesser les modèles en corse et
les références à la biologie en corse et
les autocraties ça
fonctionne moi ce que je constate c'est
que c'est s'est
défoncé des organisations qui implique
une grande participation de ceux qui
rentrent en fait et s'il n'y a pas cette
participation en
fait on se retrouve très vite des
déséquilibres en fait avec sûr c'est la
question de la scalabilité c'est un des
petites échelles on arrive à trouver des
organisations avec des systèmes de vote
et de participation qui sont bons puis
quand on doit grandir des gens vont
arriver avec d'autre motivation que ceux
qui étaient fondées qui fondait le
premier groupe de départ vont
éventuellement - participer ou pas
participé comme c'est envisagé et donc
soit le site cette organisation avec
cette capacité de s'adapter ou rejeter
la personne mais quand elle grandit ça
devient un peu plus compliqué donc des
expérimentations à petite échelle
on voit qu'ils fonctionnent mais quand
les quand ça doit s'agrandir c'est c'est
moins évident en fait parce que comme ça
c'est s'implique beaucoup participation
des acteurs est là en fantasme beaucoup
sur le fait que tout individu et
citoyens hyper actif en fait on sait
bien que c'est pas tout à fait comme ça
que ça se passe et donc ça marche auprès
de communautés très engagé en fait donc
si une communauté à un enjeu de
développer une économie circulaire et
tous ceux qui participent prouve que ils
sont très actifs là on a une dynamique
qui est intéressante et si le groupe
grandit il ya des personnes qui viennent
avec des motivations différentes c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué à gérer un fait
et rendent scalable ccsa non pour une
attention en fait c'est que balisé
petites expérimentations n'en trouvera
plein
peut-être qu elles existeront toutes les
échelles qui ne pourront pas grandi ça
n'enlève rien à leur alma à leur mérite
mais de là imaginer qu'elles deviennent
des modèles universels c'est moins
évident en fait fabrice naudé question
tu
travailles des
perspectives par rapport à ça sur
française à venir alors moi j'ai un ami
avocat qui travaille qui a travaillé sur
le dossier de la régulation des dacia
qui m'a confirmé c'est presque public
maintenant qu' il y aurait une
réalisation assez légères en fait un k
way six de base donc et aussi new york
demain c'est à dire en français ça zut
ça dure et que l'on connaît qui est
derrière quoi
et qu'ensuite ils laisseraient des
expérimentations se faire ça c'est ce
qui va être annoncé par gouvernement
septembre et donc ils veulent être ils
veulent permettre à des expérimentations
blocs
times se faire en france oui j'étais
j'étais justement ce matin le forim du
bloc jean marais n'est donc pas rare
laure de la raudière députée est
justement toute la discussion c'était un
peu autour de comment est-ce qu'on va
réguler la blood scène et c'est donc
là est ma faim effectivement est en
train de prendre des marchés financiers
est
en train de prendre donc une démarche
assez ouverte qui va donc c'est l'idée
que par définition elle ne va pas régulé
ou créer des contraintes additional sur
l'émission d'ondés tocane un sous forme
d'un trio mais par contre ils vont
fournir en visant donc lorsque un cd
acteurs décident vraiment de remplir
toutes les formalités etc elles vont
obtenir le visa de l'amf donc pour
montrer que effectivement ils ont été
certifiés par la maaf donc c'est une
approche assez intéressante parce
qu'effectivement c'est ça ça va inviter
probablement plusieurs acteurs à venir à
s'installer en france pour l'émission dé
tocane au lieu d'aller essayer de
s'échapper dans dans les juridictions
tels que gibraltar ou malte après je
pense que c'est une étape importante
donc évidemment les cios et c'est quand
même aujourd'hui c'est peut-être
l'application la plus la plus importante
de que l'on rencontre sur le blocus
après selon moi il ya vraiment beaucoup
de travail en faire encore en tout ce
qui concerne la reconnaissance de la
blocs chaînes comme faisant effet de
preuves comme étant effectivement une
signature qualifié de façon à pouvoir
vraiment déployer cette technologie pour
des utilisations qui sont vraiment
extrêmement importante en ce qui
concerne tout ce qui est l'auditabilité
la neutralisation et pourquoi pas les
smart contracte comment est ce qu'on
fait effectivement rentré dans un
contrat et s'assurer que ce contrat
informatique
il a une forme de validité ou de
reconnaissance aussi au niveau juridique
donc pour l'instant et c'est normal on
se concentre essentiellement sur tout ce
qui est applications financières parce
que c'est là où les applications elles
existent on est encore vraiment un des
phases assez immature en tout ce qui
concerne donc la lan autorisation
l'utilisation pour retourner à 3
dichotomie au début les trois lectra
catégorie donc les applications
financières celles qui ont vraiment
beaucoup de le plus d'utilisation
aujourd'hui donc c'est évidemment celle
sur lequel les régulateurs il se
concentre mais selon moi la donc là la
catégorie numéro 2 qui est vraiment
l'utilisation de la blood chaînes comme
un cadastre
aussi a besoin d'une forme de régulation
a besoin d'une reconnaissance juridique
de façon à ce que l'on considère qu
effectivement il ya une équivalence
fonctionnelle entre un contrat qui a été
émis sur un dock chez nous un contrat en
papier une signature sur la blogo chez
nous une signature un papier etc et la
façon dont va pouvoir effectivement
exploiter ces nouvelles technologies
c'est après qu'il y ait cette
reconnaissance juridique que pour
l'instant on n'en est pas encore là et
ensuite évidemment lorsqu'on rentre dans
la catégorie numéro 3 avec hall les
marques comptera que les organisations
autonomes et cetera là on rentre
vraiment dans un dans un champ qui n'a
pas encore été explorées par par les
régulateurs pourquoi tu te tais haussé
ses sujets parce
que en tant que juriste c'est
certainement un des lieux les plus
intéressants à explorer oui
moi
c'est parce que c'est un long fil
conducteur en fait j'ai commencé j'étais
consultant sur les sujets d'une nouvelle
technologie et puis je me suis concentré
sur le marché des télécoms en 2001 donc
sur des grands contes chants qui
fabrique les téléphones d'abord nos
quais en particulier et celle au caire
en parlait de de l'identité le carnet
l'adresse comme le meilleur à 7 de
l'entreprise je fais plein de
l'exploration sur ce jeu là est la
question de la décentralisation la
constitution de communautés de 2
2 le
modèle 2
je
sais plus on pioche qui
a capitalisé sur le modèle de m caf qui
disait en fait plus d'un dans un réseau
en fait on du modèle de les cartes plus
un modèle et il
est exponentielle parce que la valeur
est égale au carré du nombre de
participants et se [grognement] met que
théorisait que c'était même dans les
organisations où il y avait des groupes
qu'ils se constituaient c'était encore
plus exponentielle et donc moi mon sujet
c'est l'identité les communautés et avec
la blocage n ya des choses qui sont
intéressantes j'ai eu un labo sur la
question c'était l'identité numérique et
les mêlées sochaux ball médias donc les
médias qui créent de la sociabilité donc
moi j'y suis rentrée notamment par
primavera on s'est rencontré il ya
quelques années et puis sur sur le sous
l'angle de l'identité essentiellement et
comment l'identité la l'intégration dans
un groupe et la participation à un
groupe peut avoir une demi-queue
nouvelle avec de la décentralisation ou
des hybridations encore une fois je
crois que l'on va et on voit voir
émerger des choses qui sont pas aussi
noire blanche on
voudrait que vous nous conseillez 3 trop
livre bien
jettera de conseiller le mien a
donc je viens de je viens de son [rires]
livre qui s'appelle bloc jeunes de l'eau
et qui en fait bava identifiées
donc toutes les problématiques
juridiques soulevées par la blood chaîne
les les enjeux de régulation et
potentiellement les les avantages et les
dangers des différentes modalités de
régulation que l'on peut avoir
donc bah je conseille vivement de lire
parce que je suis trop bien ce qu'ils
veulent acheter ses serveurs coutu
prend combien dessus chouchou boucle
alors je prend 2 5% donc je suis pas en
train de promouvoir pour devenir riche
c'est pas ça qui va me rendre riche
autre niche balle et au calme dans
[rires]
ce régal
tu rigoles paris est toujours une part
de vérité dans ce qu'on dit et
à les autres livres donc un autre livre
qui est qui qui je pense est très
intéressant parce que justement il ya
une personne qui a fait un très beau
book review et qui a comparé à mon livre
avec ce livre assez radical market de
richard posner qui s'est vraiment une
exploration fascinante enfin sans sens
que je suis nécessairement d'accord avec
les revendications qui se font mais
c'est c'est sous les revendications ben
en gros il explore toutes les
possibilités dans lesquels on peut créer
des marchés pour réguler la société donc
c'est vraiment la question de la
gouvernance mais ces poussées à
l'extrême comment est ce que le marché
permet de tout régulé et donc il va
analyser différentes différents aspects
pour pour analyser en quoi une approche
de marché pourrait être plus ou moins
efficace ou optimale par rapport c'est
plus le vix qui désiraient chicago
school donc c'est le trait je suis très
très verte [raclement de gorge] à rien
je suppose mais
c'est intéressant exprès parce que
justement ça rentre vraiment dans cette
danse est problématique que est-ce que
la blocs chaîne est vraiment cette
infrastructure qui va porter à 7 à ce
crypto libertarianisme ou alors est-ce
que et je pense que c'est ce qui nous
intéresse beaucoup plus est ce que cette
technologie peut être utilisée au
contraire pour créer des nouvelles
formes de gouvernance qui sont beaucoup
plus humaine et qui permettent plus de
participations et plus de coopération
entre les individus et en fait c'est les
deux c'est d'ailleurs c'est une
technologie elle va être utilisée pour
le pour le mieux et pour le pire et
c'est intéressant donc de voir comment
est-ce que est en fait richard porte
n'analyse pas là blocs chaîne du tout
mais cdc
la même c'est les mêmes courants de
pensée que l'on remarque lorsque l'on
regarde les typologies de gouvernance
qui sont en train d'être implémenté sur
l'agglo de chine où le désir de
décentralisation justement va porter à
utiliser des mécanismes de marché sans
en fête allait réfléchir à quelles sont
les implications donc sociale et
politique de ces approches et le
troisième livre que je que je
suggérerais ca d age of m de robin van
sant ce qui est d'ailleurs le créateur
de la fuite a requis en français je sais
pas internet
va vous le dire et
à séparer ses c'est un livre qui va
explorer enfin c'est pour moi c'est des
choses qui m'intéressent j'essaye de
comprendre comment est ce que les blocs
chaîne permet de créer des formes de
gouvernance qui sont décentralisées mais
qui ne sont pas basés sur le marché et
donc ça m'intéresse beaucoup de lire la
littérature qui au contraire est en
train d'identifier ces mécanismes de
régulation par le marché et qu'ils les
promeut comme étant des mécanismes de
régulation et gustave le bon nom
psychologie des foules donc le conseil
ok merci oui alors moi je recommande
solide primavera que j'ai presque
terminé j'ai trompé non gère très bien
parce que il est didactique je dis
pourquoi pas des images non non non ce
que j'ai trouvé intéressant c'est que
cette année verra verte a demandé de le
menu primal rage un monde où un regard
critique sur le sur le à chaque cas
qu'elle expose elle parle aussi de
l'aspect this topic donc c'est pas juste
allez-y foncez dans la blue jam elle a
un regard critique et ses mérites en il
y en a un autre qui m'a beaucoup plu je
crois qu'il s'appelle de bitcoin à
burning man dans lequel
moi j'ai pris toutes mes sources en fait
ils parlent donc en fait c'est un
document de et mighty parle d'eux
des organisations au loonie qu'il ya 110
portman sur les mécaniques physique des
foules tout ce qui traite de la
gouvernance donc
sous différentes langues différentes
expertises il ya treize chapitres je
crois et c'est c'est franchement bien
fait chacun des chapitres prend la
question de la gouvernance sous un angle
différent et c'est le sujet parce que
finalement sur le sujet de la bulle
internet pour
que tu pousses ces questions non j'ai
pas ce que par politesse ainsi on
établit oui je les lis bien sûr non moi
je connais bien beaucoup des témoins
c'est pas mal c'est pas mal non je
voulais juste dire que à la plante aux
ide cet été va aller au var niggemann ok
d'accord il ya trois plateaux et qui
vont pousser dans la dans le déficit
parce que j'étais en train de prêcher
pour garder donc [rires]
cela est très bien vague amène les
plants de riz donc si obligé d'y aller
pour les poulets surveille à quoi on
verra peut-être là mais où pas question
de faire un troisième troisième
j'ai
lu
celui dont tapscott qui est un peu datés
maintenant utiliser le panorama de tout
ce qui pourrait être dit souhaiter prime
l'obtiennent c'était très dur
j'ai évolué c'est
pas mal c'est il a un mérite de courir
tous les domaines qui pourraient être
impactées mais c'est peut-être un peu
naïf maintenant mais l'introduction
lorsqu'on connaît pas du tout la bloquer
ouais il ya un très bon panorama de tout
ce qui peut être couvert par le sujet
j'avais opté non neeman s'est pas devenu
un gros scandale pourquoi
je suis pas on voit des zouzous c'est un
peu n'importe quoi est ce que l'essence
même du burning man n'est pas les pins
mais je crois que l'esprit d'herman a
disparu quand
tu es dépassé en format vidéo la nature
du ted a changé père niggemann et c'est
médiatisé je pense que la méditation
amener des personnes qui ne venaient pas
qu'ils ne sont pas c'est exactement ce
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure c'est
qu'on peut avoir des fonctionnements
très équilibré dans des communautés
jusqu'à certaine taille puis quand on
change d'échelle on a des individus qui
viennent avec des motivations
différentes et c'est c'est plus une
chose donc là les gens payent pour avoir
pour avoir du service était pas et ce
prix là ce soit les taux suffisant c'est
de laisser de ne pas laisser de traces
la nature a changé notamment quelques
solos de la vallée qui sont venus se
faire ça peut rien en hélico donc
viennent en hélicoptère fondeur truc et
ça devient a lieu pour être vus plus
qu'ils ont de vivre l'expérience de jeu
je vis dans une communauté
autosuffisante jeu et je ne laisse pas
de trace après sept communautés
éphémères bon
c'est ça
c'est dénaturer mais voulu monter un
vrai plus bien gérée par radiall ils ont
réussi à venir
non pas cette année peut-être après mais
cette année je viens avec un gros camion
et non ce que je voulais dire c'est
qu'en fait je pense là ce qui s'est
passé c'est qu'ils ont réussi a coopté
un des critères les plus fondamentales
de burning man qui est on ne peut pas
avoir des changes monétaires et en fin
de compte on n'a plus les échanges on
n'a toujours pas les échanges monétaires
à burning man mais ce qui se passe c'est
que les gens ils prêts achètent des
services et donc ils vont acheter leur
camp qui en fin de compte on va payer
vingt mille euros pour avoir un camp de
cinq étoiles est donc évidemment une
fois que je suis à burning man je
respecte les règles ou effectivement je
vais achever pas j'avais pas l'échangé
d'argent mais parce que je les ai
achetés avant et donc en fait ils ont
trouvé une mécanisme de contourner ce
critère et tout d'un coup ça a modifié
complètement la population puisque tout
d'un coup il ya les personnes qui
effectivement ne serais jamais allé s'il
devait amener leur propre tante et faire
un peu le grassroot et tout d'un coup
ils peuvent avoir leur air conditionné
leur chef qui leur cuisine etc et donc
évidemment ils vont là et puis il n'ya
plus le a pris les mêmes valeurs puisque
c'est pas les prendre de la drogue la
main à
ok
[rires]
on arrive à la fin de notre interview on
demande de laisser un conseil pour les
jeunes générations quelque chose
d'impérissables une bouteille à la mer
donc vous
de jouer oh
moi j'aimerais leur dire que les
sujets qu'on a évoqué son souhait si moi
j'étais étudiant aujourd'hui je
m'intéresserai au sujet de la bloquer
alors que pour un designer c'est pas une
évidence est un sujet extrêmement
technique priori et qui sait pas encore
démocratisée comme jeu l'éditeur n'a pas
créé da fort dense qui permettent à des
utilisateurs lambda de rentrer de
comprendre les gouvernances d'une
communauté ou d'un système est qu'il ya
beaucoup à faire pour appliquer les
méthodes centrées les utilisateurs
pourront prendre ces blocs les blocs
chaîne très utilisable et je pense que
la conseil que j'aurais une nouvelle
génération c'est intéressez-vous à
étudier tout ce qui existe sur les
dynamiques de groupe constitution de
groupes et et parce
qu'aujourd'hui je pense que c'est pas à
dépasser la question technique en fait
si on veut concevoir
des systèmes avec des blocs tony des
monnaies en fait on est dans des démunis
qui sont assez complexes finalement on
revient un peu à ce qu'on a vu avec
l'émergence de l'informatique et la
cybernétique en fait c'est se pressent
pour moi le vrai début des des
communautés interdisciplinaire dans
lequel pour moi designer le design
thinking aînés et donc il y avait des
biologistes des physiciens des designers
et
ces gens collaborer je pense que ce
sujet deux blocs chain des quelque chose
qui transcende une expertise isolé en
fait donc invités à être curieux à
collaborer avec d'autres expertises que
l'ancien pour faire que on n'a pas on
essaie de dépasser les naïvetés de son
propre domaine pour faire que les choses
soient plus scalable est plus tenable ça
je trouve que c'est un bon conseil donc
intéressez-vous dynamique de groupe tout
ce qui est lésé bitcoins burning man et
et intéressez vous à collaborer avec
d'autres disciplines pour faire avec
mais rejet des choses assez fine il y
aura le mot de la fin moi
je pense que je vais je vais leur dire
de d'être utopiste c'est
à dire de vraiment essayé d'aller
explorer en quoi cette technologie n'est
pas juste une innovation technologique
mais en quoi est ce que ça peut
engendrer une innovation sociale de
la même façon en fin de compte ou aux
débuts de l'internet il y avait tous et
toutes ses promesses et ses visions de
de créer un nouvel espace décentralisée
désintermédiés qui allait promouvoir la
liberté l'autonomie individuelle et en
fin de compte ba s'est rendu compte que
c'est pas vraiment le cas hmmm ça s'est
pas vraiment passé comment certains leur
est aspiré en fin de compte balle à
internet est devenu un outil de
surveillance et de contrôle et pour moi
c'est important aujourd'hui il ya une
nouvelle vague de il ya de nouveau c'est
narrative en fait qui sont soulevées à
de la même façon qu'on a vu avec
internet on se rend compte que petit à
petit il y à d'autres personnes qui
commencent à adopter la technologie et
qui en fin de compte ne l'adoptent pas
du tout dans la même lignée que c'est
que ces idéaux et que c'est narrative et
c'est le moi ce qui est important
justement pour les nouvelles générations
c'est au contraire de s'emparer de cette
technologie da de maintenir cette espèce
d'utopie évidemment on n'arrivera pas à
cette
société idéale décentralisée par ci
participative mais ce moment il faut
absolument il faut y croire quand même
il faut il faut se battre pour au moins
essayer d'avancer un petit peu dans
cette direction et ce qui est
fondamental selon moi c'est justement de
ne pas se concentrer uniquement sur la
technologie la technologie c'est une
innovation et je pense que c'est une
innovation importante qui va
effectivement nous comporter des
changements potentiels dans la société
mais il faut essayer d'identifier quel
est leur l'innovation sociale qui peut
ce qui peut se planquer qui peut se
placer au dessus de cette innovation
technologique parce que on si on
n'apporte pas une innovation sociale
innovations tout technologique ne va pas
comporter une modification de l'ordre
économique sociale ou politique la
technologie en tant que telle elle a des
potentiels à des opportunités mais c'est
vraiment l'innovation sociale qui va
permettre de modifier quelque chose et
donc j'invite toutes les générations
présentes et futures d'essayer de
continuer à continuer
à rêver et maintenir cette utopie pour
essayer d'explorer de
quoi il s'agit qu'est ce que c'est que
cette innovation sociale et d'essayer de
la mettre en pratique merci c'est quoi
le bouquin complet conseiller mathieu
va dire après nos psys que j'ai des
foules justement fait rémy primavera
mercy bay